[Music]  forty years ago on Halloween night  Michael Myers murdered three people  after that horrific night he was sent  back to the institution in captivity  I have prayed her every night but he  would escape hell did you do that for  so I can kill him the bus crashed  Michael Myers escaped he returned to  having filled his home I need to protect  my family you have no security system  Karen you need help evil is real there's  the reason we were supposed to be afraid  of the sight I've been preparing for  this for a long time it is not safe to  be on the street tonight he's here he is  a killer but he will be killed tonight  happy Halloween Michael  [Music]